so we have right over here we have the
vector U and we've defined it by giving
its X&Y components it's a two
dimensional vector and we have the
vector W and we've graphed them the
vector u its X component is 2 its Y
component is negative 1 so if we put its
initial point that it's at the origin
the terminal point or its head will be
at the point 2 comma negative 1 which is
right over there and for vector W its
negative 5 comma 5 so it's X its X
component is negative 5 so if we start
at the origin we would move 5 to the
left and its Y component is positive 5
so we would move five up then to get to
the head of the vector or to get to the
terminal point now given these two
vectors what we want to do is evaluate
what 3 times the vector u plus 1/5 times
the vector W is and I encourage you to
pause the video and give a go at it well
3 and 1/5 are scalars they are going to
scale these vectors and we're going to
see them see that happen visually so
we're going to scale up vector u by 3
we're going to scale down vector W we're
going to multiply it by 1/5 and then
we're going to add the resulting vectors
so let's do that so when we scale vector
u by 3 we could just view this as 3
times vector u we know is a vector 2
comma negative 1 and so that's going to
be we could write it this way let me
write the two let me write the negative
1 that's going to be 3 times 2 for the
new X component once we scale it up and
3 times negative 1 for the new Y
component and of course that's going to
be result in the vector 3 times 2 our
new X component is 6 and our new Y
component is going to be negative 3 and
so let's plot that so everything I've
done just just now is that part of the
expression that part of the expression
so the vector 6 comma negative 3 if we
started it at the origin we're going to
move so let's see we're going to move
one two three four five six in the X
direction and negative three in the Y
direction so one two three one two three
so we move we get right about there so
there you have it this is the vector
three you we're at one two three four
five six in the x-direction or six to
the right and then we went down three
one two three in the y-direction and
notice it's in the exact same direction
as vector u it is just has it just has
three times the magnitude it's that's
vector u that would be to you and then
we get two three three times the
magnitude all right now let's figure out
what 1/5 times the W is so 1/5 times W
well let me just write this which is
going to be plus 1/5 W is the vector is
the vector negative five comma five and
so this is going to be plus so that's
going to be let me write the components
down so it's going to be plus 1/5 times
1/5 times negative five and the y
component is going to be 1/5 times five
and so that's going to be plus which I
wrote 1/2 brains not working properly
1/5 times negative five and 1/5 times
five and so this part right over here is
going to be 1/5 times negative five is
negative 1 and 1/5 times five is
positive one and so this new vector 1/5
W is going to be W scaled down and so
it's negative one comma one if we
started at the origin so negative one
comma one we get right over there and
notice it's going in the same direction
as W it's just 1/5
it's just 1/5 is long and now we just
want to add these two vectors so if we
add up by just looking at its components
the resulting vector the resulting
vector when we do
and any new and a new color that I have
not used yet so the resulting vector
we're going to add the corresponding X
components so it's going to be 6 plus
negative 1 6 plus negative 1 and the
resulting Y component is going to be
negative 3 plus 1 negative 3 plus 1 and
so the resulting vector is going to be
equal to 5 comma 5 comma negative 2 and
we could also see that visually if we
start with this blue vector 3 times the
vector U and we were to add the green
vector 1/5 W well we were to add that we
would just start at the head of 3 u we
would when we are going to add negative
1 comma once we're going to move one to
the left and one up we're going to get
right over there so let me see if I can
draw that
so just to be a little head to tail
method right over here so the head of
the first vector is going to be where
the tail of the next vector starts that
we're adding and so the resulting vector
is going to be if we started it at the
tail of the first vector of 3 u right
over here or at the origin and then we
bring it to the head of the second
vector we get once again the vector v
comma negative 2 its x-component is 5 we
move v to the right and we move 2 down